hello everyone so I'll start off by
telling you a quick story there was a
rabbi who often would give sermons from
a pulpit kind of like this on Saturday
mornings and he gave the best sermons
they were they rocked the house and they
would last sometimes 15 minutes 20
minutes sometimes they're really good a
half hour would really get into it the
spirit was moving him and people loved
it so one Saturday morning at the
reception after service as one of his
members comes up to him we'll call the
number for lack of a name mr. Cohen and
mr. Cohen says I run a daytime talk show
and I would love to get you on that talk
show what you talked about today was so
inspiring I think like it'll just move
the audience can you can you just make
some time to come out to the talk show
on Tuesday morning and the rabbi says
like I guess I'll do that sure why not
but there's only one problem mr. Cohen
says he says you speak so powerfully but
the slot is only for two minutes just
two minutes it's it's a TV show we have
two snippets and the rabbi says no
problem I can bring that down to two
minutes and Cohen says if you can do
that for the top show if you do that
every week sure I know I'm the pen
ultimate talk before lunch so I don't
know about you but in my community lunch
is a big deal food is a big deal so I
understand if your stomach says I'm a
little hungry so I'll try and be concise
and keeps the 25 minutes although a fair
warning rabbis can be a little verbose
we can be a little long-winded but I
will try and keep it down so the talk
for today is preparing for the technical
interview and I think it's a really
important one for people who like me
came into coding came into this field
from backgrounds that were not the
traditional backgrounds meaning I didn't
graduate with a computer science degree
a logic degree a math degree I majored
in psychology and minored in political
science and a lot of theology and so how
do you prepare for these conversations
when you don't come from that place so
just first a little about Who I am so
I miss work I was born and raised in San
Diego it's a beautiful city at the very
edge of California right on the border
with Mexico a great childhood a lot of
time at the beach a lot of fun and I
also was a bit of a nerd in San Diego
and so I helped to create a couple
meetings this is from 2000 I think this
website this was the San Diego 2600
meeting is any remember 2600 magazine I
see a hand 2600 magazine 20-under
magazine was like a hacker magazine it
was cool in the 90s early 2000s and they
had like meetings throughout the world
so I created the San Diego Chapter this
2600 meeting and this was our website
and it just recently got a facelift
apparently capital W capital S that just
tells you so much about the time and and
I'm up all the way up there I was skal
or because I liked ska music so I'm like
let's get into skal Laurie I was made a
major nerd and so in the san diego 2600
meeting we also created torque on and
contrast is awful oh but I apologize
torque on torque on is a computer
security InfoSec conference it was
started in 1999 it's in its 20th year
next year and now there's three tour
cons there's torque on San Diego torque
on Seattle tour camp which is happening
a couple of weeks in Washington State
five days and there's also tour world
which is a cruise in it in Antarctica
a hacker Cruise in Antarctica and so I
was about 15 or 16 when we created this
conference my parents had to sign off on
the room reservations at the UCSD a
price center where I had we had the
first event now it happens at the
convention center and this was the
announcement I sent out to some
listservs that's me up there as was 1999
tour con San Diego California is only
only all-caps comprehensive love the
language computer security conference
and what we're gonna do there we're
gonna bring a comprehensive interactive
and enjoyable conference to the western
United States that will help make the
public
aware of the importance of computer
security and it costs a whopping 35
bucks to come to the conference it now
is a little more expensive in its 20th
year but it was $35 and so after that
from my childhood in San Diego and being
a bit involved in computers I moved to
New York so from the sunny San Diego to
New York and that's what it looks like
all year if you never been there believe
me that's just that's New York City and
I went to New York to a small liberal
arts Jewish college in Queens in the
neighborhood of Flushing New York and we
were minute flushing flushing is awesome
flushing is like basically one of the
most diverse neighborhoods I think in
the United States it's an amazing place
and but I went to the opposite of a
diverse experience I went to an all-male
very small ultra-orthodox Jewish college
where we spent from about 9:00 in the
morning to about six o'clock at night in
religious studies and from 6 to about
9:00 p.m. in college and then from 9 to
11 back in religious studies so I had a
lot of free time I was just hanging out
of New York all the time I really got to
see New York I barely left from the dorm
to the school back to the dorm to the
school and a couple years into my
college experience a magazine in San
Diego reached out to me for this really
tacky article and I just want to show
one quick quote to highlight what I was
actually doing you know those like
graphics like what you people think
you're doing versus what you're actually
doing in life so then this article from
2003 they're like my mind wandered off
to Ben Greenberg had he really gone to
rabbinical school maybe he hadn't oh no
but this is what I was actually doing I
was studying Talmud all day essentially
which is a book of many many books of
Jewish thought in Jewish law written in
Aramaic and Hebrew letters which is a
wonderful ancient language it's still
spoken in some parts of Syria and it's
spoken in amongst the Jewish community
so I was studying that and then once I
became a rabbi I was doing things like
this talking about matzah and holding up
a piece of matzah because every rabbi
needs a picture of themselves holding a
piece of matzah
it's very important it's like you
graduate you learn Torah and you have to
hold matzah these are the two essential
ingredients I was actually at this point
leading a social justice Passover Seder
in the southside of Chicago on the topic
of gun violence which if you're not from
the states is still regrettably a major
issue and I was at that time community
organizer in Chicago and so that was
what I was actually doing in my life I
wasn't doing anything else I'd actually
gone through a pinnacle school but then
fast-forward 10 years and I decided I
wanted to have a change in pace and I my
10-year mark in my career I said you
know I could either keep on doing this
for life I can go back to being what I
really love which is a nerd and I went
to Flatiron school which is a boot camp
in New York City it's now part of the
wework family via international
co-working space and at the Flatiron
school I met a lot of people like me I
met graphic designers and musicians and
artists and teachers and lawyers and
salespeople and yes rabbis in fact my
colleague at the company I work at now
as a developer who sits right behind me
is also a former rabbi who went to the
Flatiron school we went together so and
we're not the only ones we faculty have
a hosts slack channel just four rabbis
turn developers the conversations are
fascinating it's a mix of Hebrew and
English and Yiddish all the time it's
awesome if you want to know how to like
say some coding terminology and get ish
we can talk later so and we transition
the coding for a lot of reasons we did
it because we love the ability to create
coding wall it's incredibly technical
it's a highly highly technical field
it's an incredibly creative field and
for those of us who come from other
creative professions whether it was art
or clergy or somewhere else you get it
exercised that part of your brain all
the time as a programmer in different
ways in totally different modalities but
you still get to create all the time and
we also love it because of jobs there's
a lot of jobs as a programmer New York
City there are tons of programming jobs
it is awesome when you have a family to
support it's even
better and we love it because of the
excitement of learning you never stop
learning as a programmer it actually
reminds me of my rabbinical school
education it never ends you know every
time I open a blog post like what is
that word what does that even mean
like now there's another JavaScript
framework like how can I pick up that it
just never never stops and we also love
it because of jobs and I say that
already I think I did we love the fact
that we can make an impact when we're
working at whatever kind of company we
work at I work at a financial services
company if you work at a non-profit you
can really make a difference you go to
work and when it's a good day and not
every day is obviously a good day but
when you go ahead have a good day you
can leave that day and you say I've
actually done something quantitatively
done something I started here and I
ended here and there's something really
powerful about that and we also love
jobs yeah there's the theme and we love
the remote work culture there was a day
where my car had an issue and I had to
take it to the shop so I took my laptop
to the shop then I went to a coffee shop
and then I went somewhere else and then
somewhere else that were from home and
those of you who work remotely I'm only
a little jealous of you but we love the
fact you can really take your worth with
you and of course there's some downsides
that as well but the idea that you're
not you don't have to be tethered to a
desk all day or all night and we also
have jobs yes and did I mention jobs
jobs are awesome and I put that there
several times not only to be funny but
because yes this is a great career for
people who are looking for something
that's exciting something you can make
an impact something that has a remote
work culture something where you can
really create and a lot of potential to
actually take care of yourself to take
care of your family and to be
economically secure which in this world
we really can't take for granted and so
in the in the bootcamp process first
comes the learning and the learning is
awesome it's hard to describe how
awesome the learning is you start from
nothing I mean the last time I coded was
in Perl and and you start and JavaScript
was not really a thing in 1997 and so
you start learning everything anew
essentially and it never ends it's like
an endless sea
of functions and methods and you're like
I like the gems of Ruby and I like the
snakes of Python I like all these things
and it's so awesome and then when you're
ready at some point whether you finish
the bootcamp or your self Todd and you
feel like you're ready to get out there
in the job market so you got to polish
the resume and if they wonder about how
do I turn all this non tech experience
into a resume that won't just get thrown
out by the filters and then you polish
that resume you start going on
interviews you have those cultural
interviews why do you want to work here
because you'll pay me and then and then
you get past those cultural
conversations and then you get to the
white board and the white board can be
absolutely terrifying if you're anyone
anyone whether you come from a CS
background you don't come from a CS
backgrounds whether you've done this for
a long time or you're doing this just
for the first day it's a terrifying
experience and it's even more so I would
imagine and I know I don't know your
experience if you converse yeah Specter
I know my experience that if you don't
it's it's a nightmare because on
multiple levels there's multiple points
for why it's challenging one is at the
boot camp
whatever boot camp you went to the
chances are you learned how to do things
you learned maybe you learned react you
learn JavaScript you learned I may be
another language Ruby is a fun one to
learn a boot camps you learn you learn
how to code right but you don't
necessarily learn the algorithms you
don't learn about data structures you
don't learn about the things that you
will learn if you go to a four year
traditional CS degree and yet oftentimes
when you're standing in front of that
whiteboard and all you have is that
marker and that and and the eraser and a
bunch of eyes intently staring at you
and watching you they're asking you what
kind of questions
they're often asking you questions about
data structures are there asking
algorithmic questions they're not asking
you to like create a react component on
the whiteboard they're not asking you to
like create a function that like does X
Y or Z or you know even like the fun
ones like palindrome functions give me
palindrome functions those are fun like
they're not asking those they're asking
typically algorithmic questions which
you don't prepare for so what do you do
all day when you're not interviewing I
had in my backpack a little tiny
whiteboard that I took with me
everywhere and whether I was in between
picking my kids up from daycare or I was
at a coffee shop I had the whiteboard
out and I was practicing and practicing
and practicing and practicing
algorithmic questions and I had that big
book you know a big book I'm talking
about cracking the coding interview book
and it simultaneously freaked me out and
freaked me out
basically and I just practiced all that
looked like I looked a little crazy you
know sitting in Starbucks with a
whiteboard you know writing things that
kinda look like English but not really
English
you're like what is that guy doing do I
need me worried and so that's what I did
and so what I want to do with our time
remaining time is to talk about how we
can go from this to this in this
experience and I'm not going to solve it
and it's we're not necessarily going to
go from all the way from this all the
way to that but hopefully we'll go from
like a total nightmare to not as freaked
out might be the goal and these things
come from my own experiences just things
that helped me to prepare at general
principles so we're gonna top with some
of the general principles and then we're
going to apply them to one example a
relatively easy example but an example
that we can cover in the time we have so
first principle is to know your
strengths know what you're good at so if
you come to this field with a liberal
arts degree it's not like you come from
ground zero you have skills they may not
be the same exact skills or s you're not
necessarily as strong in the exact
skills that somebody came from a CS
background has but you also have skills
that they might not have as well and if
you understand the skills that you do
have you know where you are strong you
can actually translate some of the
problems into a language that resonates
with you and so language that speaks to
you so for example which one of these
makes more sense to you this
does that make sense anyone I see a
couple head nods or this is that makes
sense to anyone so this makes absolutely
no sense to me that might as well be
like Greek or something and no offense
people heard from Greece it might as
well be Greek this doesn't make sense at
first but I know English and I know
English really well and so I can
actually parse this and translate it
into something that's meaningful the
negation of a disjunction is the
conjunction of the negations essentially
like the opposites right the negation of
a something is together is the
conjunction of two things that are not
the same right so you can translate
things that's de Morgan's laws it's a
logic principle and so often times
whiteboard interviews are presented the
challenge is presented from somebody who
comes from a world where this makes a
lot more sense than this and so the
question with the unintended bias the
the biases that we all carry around in
ourselves on a plethora of things
whatever they are
we also biases for how we learn and so
we'll present to someone who's
interviewing a certain way a formulation
of a question thinking that might be an
easier way to understand it but
ultimately for the person interviewing
that might not be the way that they
think it you know so in general and by
the way it's also okay that if neither
of these made sense right it's okay
because it's complicated but in general
technically minded people people who
have a more technical proclivity we like
to limit the number of words and so it's
all about being lazy right being a lazy
programmer being as efficient as
possible with a minimum amounts of
typing you can possibly type like if I
can have a shortcut in my IDE that like
will put a whole function there that's
amazing I want to do that and I want to
make sure I can only if I can do this in
15 words or 15 keystrokes but or I can
do it in three I'll do three obviously
readability is an issue as well but you
want to limit the number of words
liberal-arts people like to think about
how we can turn one word into a sentence
how can we make one sentence in their
paragraph how to make one paragraph into
an essay and how to make one essay into
an entire dissertation you know that was
essentially what you did you
so rabbis talked for a long time
sometimes in their sermons clergy
priests rabbis Imams talk for a long
time in their sermons and it's often
because we like to talk about the idea
over and over again I want to make sure
that you really got what I'm talking
about
if I say it one time two times three
times that's not enough for you I need
to say it four times and five times
maybe for you like over there eight
times I need to see the idea so many
times and at the end of it you think you
did a good job in your congregations
like what the heck just happens like do
they think they think I'm an idiot
but it's because we're very four boats
and I'm being verbose right now by
talking about a lot I'm demonstrating it
and so so that's very important we all
translate into a language that speaks
for you principle number two is every
building starts with the first brick
every complex idea every complex idea is
ultimately a collection of smaller ideas
and those smaller ideas been broken down
into even smaller ideas it's kind of
like a multi-dimensional array you can
break down ideas and unpack them unpack
them and unpack them until you get to
that first foundational idea and then so
you're presented with the building the
problem is the building and your job if
this is helpful for you is to
deconstruct the building you know it
thank you to deconstruct the building
and then build it back up again so if
you deconstruct it and then build it
back up again that can help you
understand more and lastly principle
number three interviewing is iterative
it's an iterative process at first I was
horrible at it I'm still pretty bad at
it I don't know I'm talking about it but
interviewing is an iterative process and
if you understand your failures as
opportunities to grow from them then
you'll get better so this is a quote I
really like it's from a rabbi from
Brooklyn and the 20th century rabbi gets
caught Kutner and he wrote that the
righteous person falls seven times it
rises again because the knowledgeable
are aware that the essence of their
rising again is because of their seven
falls it's not in spite of your seven
falls it's actually because you fell and
it and you know you don't need a rabbi
or a priest or any mom to tell you this
there's so much has self-help literature
out there like look at that handsome guy
but a nice punim we would say or a nice
face but a handsome guy wrote a book
called win at losing how our biggest
setbacks can lead to our greatest gains
and that's not alone there's an entire
go to Barnes and Noble and Slyke an
entire like half of bookstore it's on
the topic of like how to win by losing
and ultimately because it's there's a
lot of truth to that and so let's take
an example binary search it's a good
example it's a relatively simple example
we can apply these principles to it
so what is it so applying pencil number
one know your strengths move there we go
so binary is not a word that's typically
in the lexicon of Liberal Arts folks so
let's break down the word binary binary
essentially is one or the other right
zero or one on or off
one or the other search it's a method of
searching in one or the other place so
what's that similar to it's similar to
finding your name at a conference you
find your name at a conference if your
name is like mine Greenberg you're not
gonna start at the very end of the table
and you're probably not gonna start at
the very beginning of the table but
you're gonna start relatively near the
beginning and you're gonna see that you
landed at D or lands it at F and then
you're gonna narrow and limit down
that's essentially binary search so
that's a probably that principle one
brick at a time it's an ordered list the
list is split into two and I have a
desired value so I'm gonna look through
that something I find its closest to it
I look through that section and is it
there yes it is there then we party it's
awesome it's there we're so happy is it
not there no then at least we can
eliminate range of values and we can
make two new sections and then until we
found it and we found it then we are so
happy and in fact psychologists tell us
looking at cute puppies makes us happy
so let's just do that one more time do
you feel the serotonin feel happy it's
awesome yeah right it's great so we're
very happy we looked at a cute puppy
that's essentially it and applying
principle my three interviewing is
iterative and so you're at that
whiteboard you don't know what to do so
you the one thing not to do with the
whiteboard is to freeze write something
down it may not be the perfect thing it
may not be the best thing
but at least it's something so for me
and I know I'm a relatively new
developer but this is how fast
JavaScript moves for me it's much easier
to think in es5 than es6 it's more
natural for me like I jumped to es5 two
function declarations and I know
interviewers might say want might want
to see you declare a function with es6
syntax or is he really like hip and cool
does he know the newest stuff but like
it's easy but I don't want to just
freeze at the board and do nothing
so I start writing something I'll just a
clarification it's not nothing in it yet
but I know I need items I need a value
so I declare a function and then I'm
gonna declare some variables and then
I'll write the rest of it and it's not
perfect it's totally not perfect it's
table doesn't take case of edge cases
doesn't factor in any of those issues in
math top-floor might not be super fast
it's not the best function in the world
but it gets the job done and then when
you get their job done you've got to do
the best part of the whiteboard
interview what you got to talk about
your code because while you're talking
about your code with the interviewers
then you ever not portunity to actually
think about it
out of the stress of writing it and you
can go back and you can start making it
better because can that be made better
yes we can we can make it better by
making it into es6 and we can use via
bitwise or 0 operator which is not again
not a perfect thing either but it is
performance perspective it is actually
faster we've taken to least one edge
case but if the value is less than the
first thing and greater than the last
thing let's just exit out of it because
you don't need to continue the search we
switch the if-else statement into a
ternary operator we do a little bit to
at least make it a little better and can
we make that better of course we can
make that better are we gonna do it
right now no because I got one minute
left but we can totally make that better
and it can keep on improving because
interviewing is iterative because
interviewing coding learning growing
living are all if this was flower is
interative is iterative all this stuff
your life is iterative the process is
iterative
so to recap three principles know what
your brain power is take the building
apart one brick at a time and rinse wash
and repeat and ultimately I'll leave you
with one quote because I have to because
I am a rabbi still quote from Jewish
tradition this is from around
the 200 Cee Lo a la caja Mahalo guava
lohit a veteran leave a tell me mana
which essentially means it's not your
responsibility to finish the work but
neither you free to desist from it
the thing that is both amazing about
programming is the never ending journey
but if you see that the journey is
actually the destination and not
continually get freaked out that you're
never gonna end
then it becomes a process is not only a
freaking out moment on interviews but
actually comes an enjoyable experience
thank you very much